one of the big surprises of the draft
jalen hurts taking in round two by the
philadelphia eagles i caught up with gm
howie roseman yesterday and asked him
about taking hertz with a franchise
quarterback and carson wentz on the
roster here's what roseman had to say
we love carson wentz and we've shown it
with our actions we showed it when we
traded everything to go and get him we
showed it when we went and paid him on
that contract and it's not like we're
trying to get out of that contract like
we're committed to that but we're trying
to build a football team that has
incredible depth that we have this value
of this backup quarterback position you
know jeffrey said like we want to have
two of the top 10 quarterbacks in the
league like that's our goal that's what
we're trying to do so do we see jalen
hurts on the field clear this up for me
because there's this idea that he's
going to be like a taste some hill we'll
see him in different capacities two
quarterbacks on the field at the same
time
even as he's serving as an understudy to
carson wentz will we see that
you know that's that's a better question
for coach peterson you know i'm not
trying to dunk it but i'm also you know
don't feel like that's that's my dojo
do you envision that in your own mind do
you think i'd like to see this guy out
there and see what he can do in a
different capacity than quarterback
regardless of what the coach is going to
do
i love carson wentz man i i love carson
wentz and i love going to head to bed
and i put my head in on the pillow and
knowing that we have a strong
quarterback room that that to me
makes me sleep better
see i'm having a hard time understanding
what roseman's message was there i kept
trying to get him to talk about jalen
hurts being used in that gadget capacity
as taysom hill and when he talks about
how much he loves carson wentz and he
wants to protect and support carson
wentz i i can't help but wonder peter
whether or not he's going to want to
keep jalen hurts in bubble wrap because
jalen hurts is there primarily
to be that insurance policy against the
next inevitable carson wentz injury
anything that howie roseman says right
now about using jalen hurts is viewed as
a subtraction
of carson wentz it's not viewed as a hey
this is going to make us all better so
that's why
my gut feeling that's why how he
answered the question that way because
he just simply does not want to get into
this and he doesn't want there to be a
headline of roseman sees great benefits
to jalen hurts you know he just
he doesn't want i mean if i'm reading
the tea leaves that's what i think but
mike
the philadelphia eagles are an
absolutely separate
quarterback situation they have a
distinct
different quarterback situation than
most in the nfl and you say well what
does that mean
what i say is that carson wentz
in the playoff runs of 2017 and 2018
missed 13 games with injuries eight in
the regular season five in the
postseason
and
when your quarterback does that you have
to make sure that you have a backup
quarterback that you can put in instead
of saying all is lost when the detroit
lions lost matthew stafford all was lost
you know when the jets didn't have sam
darnold it's not anywhere near that
situation all was lost so
they the philadelphia eagles in my
opinion are different from 25 of the
teams in football in that in my opinion
on the philadelphia eagles two of the 10
most important players are the
quarterback and the backup quarterback
so in other words you have to devote
resources beyond the nate sutfeld kyle
lawletta level
as your backup quarterback with the
philadelphia eagles because
the odds say
that there's a decent chance you're
going to have to play him and you might
have to play him in some pretty
important snaps
yeah i i think there's a a lot of good
that what peter's saying there i do
think that's the truth i mean mike we
talk about this all the time teams that
we look at as a super bowl or playoff
contender and why the why they risk you
know the the the ability of their team
to win football games when their
starting quarterback goes out and then
we go like peter's saying well but the
season's over man our starter's gone why
do that when you have a team that you
know can make a deep playoff run and
maybe get to a super bowl why make it
all about one player and if he gets hurt
we're all screwed so i do think there is
that thought process and how can there
not be howie roseman doug peterson so
smart they know how to run the
organization there and of course carson
wentz injury history but i don't think
it's about competition or anything about
replacing carson wentz here this is
different than green bay and aaron
rodgers you know jalen hurts does have a
a specific you know athletic skill set
to where he's going to be able to add to
this offense you know again this is a
coaching staff that's came from andy
reid west coast offense similar
terminology to a sean payton who runs
the west coast offense they see what
taysom hill has done for them and hertz
is a great leader so you almost get two
positions in one but i do think that
philadelphia is not doing this to
threaten carson wentz in any way you
know when robbie roseman says he's their
guy i believe him i mean they they
traded away a lot of picks and stuff to
get there to pick carson wentz as the
number two pick in the draft they got
rid of nick foles who was a super bowl
winning quarterback because they
believed in carson wentz and they paid
him like they believed in carson wentz
so i think it's more about jalen hurts
helping out the offense and then that
insurance policy is the second part of
the whole picture
and chris you mentioned from time to
time that john gruden the raiders coach
views his offense like a ferrari and he
trusts the quarterback with the keys in
philadelphia the quarterback is the
ferrari and when you know that that
ferrari is going to get crashed from
time to time your insurance policy
becomes more expensive and you have to
devote the resources to the premium and
the premium here is jalen hurts in round
two because you know based on history
that you're going to need a backup
quarterback who isn't just standing
there on the sideline but he's ready at
a moment's notice to enter the game case
in point when carson wentz got hit
illegally by genivian clowney in the
wild card game it was over for the
evening this isn't done all the work
they put in to get there gone in an
instant but but all that said all that
said i don't know why they won't embrace
this notion of of hertz doing other
things while he's waiting to replace
carson wentz because that will at least
make the fan base feel better
about why this was done because the fan
base they don't i don't know why they
don't want to process it but they don't
they want help for carson wentz they
want a shiny new object that's going to
be on the field why not tell them hey we
are going to use hertz we get we get the
the best of both worlds here we get a
guy who's going to be on the field from
time to time and to take some hill
package and we have a guy who's going to
back up carson wentz when he gets hurt
again i don't understand why they won't
just just say that that i i didn't i
didn't think that was all that
controversial of a take for for howie
roseman to embrace
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports